when the Bible is brought into a  discussion about abortion especially it  is nine times out of ten or maybe 9.9  times out of 10.  someone on the left who brings it up so  they are the ones constantly bringing  religion and the Bible and Jesus into  not just the abortion conversation but  any conversation about a social issue  they constantly bring that in and then  they accuse us  of basing our entire uh  point of view on the Bible and religion  well you're only saying that because of  the Bible you're only saying that  because of relief so uh you know  on one hand  we only we only are saying this because  we're following the Bible as if that  would be a bad thing anyway  but then on the other hand the Bible  doesn't say that